I smoke weed once in a while I part
games here and there or I stream movies
and TV shows illegally we hear that all
the time online whether on YouTube or
even on TV not only this but a lot of
times we see people commit such crimes
on YouTube even make tutorials about
them like how to get Grand Theft Auto
for free how to get paid apps and music
for free or we may see them throwing a
super card down a rural road where
they're clearly breaking a speed limit
so how can all these people safely
continue to do this and post about
online without any repercussions well
first of all one similarity between many
of these cases is that they're usually
civil cases not criminal the offense
described in such confessions are
usually monetary losses pirating or
streaming Louis big corporations money
but does not propose any harm to public
safety so the government doesn't really
care about them to bring a civil case to
trial a party must first file a
complaint so in such scenarios the
corporation's would have to file a
complaint but the problem is what are
they going to sue for 99 cents for a nap
six dollars for a movie ticket or
perhaps even a solid $30 for a month of
Adobe Creative Cloud subscription even
if they were promoting venues to pirates
at software media how would they be able
to objectively identify how many people
who watched the video I actually ended
up falling through and hiring the post
product furthermore how would you be
able to identify how often the people
who did end up pirate product actually
used it maybe a person just wanted to
try out a piece of software and only
used it for a couple of days this person
may have only caused a company less than
$50 in losses on the other hand a person
may have loved it and used it for years
leading to hundreds of dollars in losses
so it's impossible to really analyze the
damage caused by a pirating tutorial and
even if it was possible it is highly
likely at the toy losses would have cost
less than hundred thousand dollars in
losses this is simply not worth it for
big companies to pursue civil cases are
not only long and tedious but also quite
expensive and the worst part is that at
least in America each party has to pay
for
their own legal fees according to the
American rule as a result it makes no
sense to spend tens of thousands of
dollars on lawyers and gathering enough
evidence to actually sue a defendant
simply a profit less than fifty K plus
suing such people is not going to stop
others from continuing to make such
tutorials and causing further losses
considering this it is much more
effective for companies to simply patch
the exploit or take down a service
providing the illicit content rather
than going against the people who are
simply sharing it online not only would
this be a faster and more efficient
process but also significantly cheaper
these companies already have security
teams and hackers who have successfully
cracked software usually take advantage
of low-level kernels or exploits so it
would just take a couple of hours for
professional security teams to make a
patch followed up by a simple update if
it was a video on YouTube or download
link on some website it would be very
easy for companies to flag such venues
and take them down and this actually
happens quite often for instance a few
years ago a YouTube channel named Apple
tech spot with over a million
subscribers who posted videos here and
there about how to get free music and
apps got terminated altogether and this
is very common among download links and
videos of such nature so overall for
pirating the bottom line is that suing
is simply not financially smart nor very
effective and this is why people are
able to get away with such confessions
or posting such content company's best
option is to take down the content or
simply patch the exploit not pursue
legal solutions but what about criminal
cases if one confesses to speeding or
using illicit drugs that would be a
state or federal offense so how is this
possible while these are state or
federal offenses these are very
low-level offenses and oftentimes won't
even warrant a misdemeanor for instance
speeding or not completely stopping at
stop signs or petty crimes that almost
everyone has committed one time or
another furthermore past intoxication is
not a crime anyone can claim that they
have been high in the past even directly
to a prosecutor and even if they are
telling the truth
they can't be prosecuted because being
high is not a crime
it is the possession of illicit drugs
that is a crime the thing is that these
people online aren't confessing to
homicide or drug trafficking and even if
they were it would be very difficult to
actually prosecute them if there was a
video of a supposed to drug deal where
is it proof that the people in the video
were actually trading drugs maybe they
were just acting and maybe the cocaine
they traded was actually just powdered
sugar you can have someone admitting to
a crime in written form and it wouldn't
mean anything in court all of this is
just hearsay for a confession to hold
evidentiary value it must be stated by
the defendant under oath at a court
hearing as this is not happening when
people confess online this cannot be
used against them furthermore there's
absolutely no evidence of the event
actually occurring there are no
witnesses no time information known
location information nothing
what if they smoked marijuana at a
location where the drug was legal like
in Colorado it's basically impossible
for police to gather enough evidence to
actually prosecute a person who has
given such a confession and definitely
not worked at time for such petty crimes
on the other hand for serious crimes
they will definitely investigate further
for instance when Maddy Roberts
suggested to raid area 51 and actually
gain lot of traction online
the FBI was quick to go to his house and
thoroughly investigate him as this was
an issue dealing with national security
so yes for serious threats high level
prosecutors will get involved but over
all four issues including some sort of
parting these are classified under
several cases and it makes more
financial sense for companies simply
patch to issue or takedown download
links for petty crimes like using drugs
or speeding it's very difficult to
gather evidence to actually prosecute a
given person it's basically like trying
to prosecute a random person off the
street finally for serious admissions
well these are investigated very
seriously but as 99% of confessions fall
in the first two categories we never see
these people have any action taken
against them despite that I would
strongly advise not to make such
confessions because it just seems like a
stupid
thing to do and companies and
prosecutors can try to stew or convict
you if they so desired so the best thing
to do if you do get away with such small
things is it just keep to yourself
but that is what I think if you guys
would like to see more questions just
like this one answered logically then
make sure to subscribe and drop a like
if you thought this video clearly
answered this question but until next
time I'm hari I'll see you guys on the
next one